my name is star Hoffman I'm the
journalism and digital resources
librarian here at Columbia University
and I am a member of the symposium
committee you can see all the committee
members and volunteers have these lovely
bright orange tags so if you have any
questions please be sure to find
somebody with a bright orange tag um and
I want to say thanks to all of my fellow
planning committee members today for all
their hard work Barbara rockenbach at
least Jordan M le ransom and Don mxu and
we're just really excited that that you
all came and thank you to all our
volunteers for all their hard work
they'll be answering any questions you
have pointing out where restrooms are
and they'll also be helping you get to
the lunch venue which is downstairs in
this same building ok so we're going to
open today we have opening remarks from
Robert woven who is the associate
university librarian for bibliographic
services and collection development here
at Columbia University Libraries he's a
frequent speaker and writer on issues
related to digital content metadata and
technical services and libraries and he
served on many planning and advisory
groups including for the Library of
Congress so please help me welcome Bob
woman
so over the course of the next several
hours I know you'll be hearing a lot
more in a lot more depth on some of the
themes that I'll introduce here and I
won't try to compete with our other
speakers and those in those areas what I
will hope to do in the next 15 minutes
or so is to just offer some general
reflections on the concept of leadership
and leadership development and I hope
with with any luck some of those will
resonate with other themes that are that
are discussed later in the day and do if
not you'll hear a bunch of crazy
crackpot ideas and be able to criticize
them and so forth so when I'm thinking
about the qualities that I associate
with with a leader I really tend to
cluster that into two groups on the one
hand we have the kinds of qualities
necessary to craft a vision and
articulate a vision for others and that
includes things like creativity
imaginations supple thinking and of
course the passion to believe deeply in
an idea and care about having it
realized in actuality so a great ideas
deeply felt and then there's another
cluster alongside of that of the the
personal qualities that enable someone
to put something across that attract
followers to an idea charisma
persuasiveness you know the ability to
inspire people and so forth so a bunch
of the clusters idea associated with
personality so if you take this this
these two size of leadership you might
say that leadership is either in your
genes or in your genes that's the case
may be this suggests though that
leadership is innate that you know it's
all in born and given the themes that
we're talking about today the question
arises you know can we take the like
woebegone model and everyone's above
average and can we expect anyone and
everyone to be a leader and I won't go
into depth on that because we'll be
exploring that in some detail but this
first quote here comes from Stephen
Leacock one of his parodies of 19th
century novels of the romantic hero and
you know if you substitute the word lead
for Road
there I think you have one of the risks
we have by just harping on leadership
all the time you know leadership is
something that evolves it can be
fostered but you can't force it and so
you run the risk of desperation god
we've gotta lead ugly work and I lead
and then on the other hand leader is
something that comes about whether you
want to or not and there's always the
possibility that you will find yourself
in a situation where you're called upon
to be a leader without ever having
intended to and that's I think one of
the reasons we are going to be exploring
things like how to develop leadership so
that you're ready for it when the time
comes similarly you know the image that
comes to mind line with first image that
comes with a leader is you've got the
general on the white horse waving the
sword leading on thousands of troops but
there are many styles of leadership many
opportunities in different ways of
leading and I would suspect that mother
Teresa there on the Left never thought
of herself as never intended to be a
leader probably never even thought of
herself as being a leader and yet by her
mode of living she has become an icon
for a set of ideals and a way of living
that's inspired a great many people and
that's not leading I don't know what is
and then on the right the the women's
rights movement in nineteenth-century
america was benefited enormously by the
fact that it didn't depend on a single
great individual taking the whole burden
on themselves but on a number of strong
women grouping together and leading in a
collaborative cooperative fashion going
forward and I'm sure these are both
teams that will also be explored
throughout the course of the day we also
tend to think of leadership I think in
positive terms it just evokes those
kinds of terms but it's worth
remembering that you can be a very
effective leader and do very bad things
so I sure everyone recognizes the man on
the
how many people know the man on the
right okay James Jones jonestown
drinking the kool-aid you get you
inspire people to drink poison kool-aid
and we don't want that to happen either
now I'm not suggesting that at the end
of this meeting today you're going to
know how to become the next dictator of
the world or madman or anything like
that but it's worth remembering that
leadership is a means to something it's
not an end in itself and so that's a
theme I'd like to consider as we go
forward and moving on it's possible to
have all the qualities i just described
to be either a natural or a developed
leader and to go wrong somewhere along
the line and these i just want to offer
three three ways this can happen three
possibilities for leadership going awry
a little conversation ahead of time
suggest suggested this one of our tribe
of it before if you're out there by
yourself nobody's following you you're
not really a leader and especially early
in a career you've got a great idea you
want to put it forward you're impatient
to see it happen you want to get it
going and there's always the risk that
I've heard this myself you know a little
bit later you say you know I tried to
lead but that those people just didn't
listen that organization is just too
conservative to follow now if your great
idea is that slavery is wrong or that
gay people should have rights you
probably don't want to wait and be
patient and get people comfortable with
that idea over many years but if your
great idea is there's a better way to
catalog a book you doesn't hurt to take
the time to develop it and let it mature
to let go this is one of my favorite
because it's one of the risks that I
face myself you start out with a great
idea and you actually gets people to
believe in it and follow along but in
the process of that you inevitably have
to simplify things and getting stuck on
idea becoming too wedded to your own
ideas is a risk that I think you can
face in the course of trying to lead so
once you find that people are on board
and they're agreeing with you it's time
to get a critical look at yourself
I what's going on what happen i change
this and move things forward again not
get stuck at the point that we've always
originally aiming at and finally nobody
should lead forever and all the time so
this is a risk that I think we
contribute to not as leaders but just as
people in the world in the profession
once you see someone doing a good job
being a successful leader you tend to
look to them for leadership but we don't
want to look to the same people for
leadership all the time we want people
who will stand aside and let others step
into that role and move forward well if
all these things can go wrong if you can
become a lousy leader even though you're
effective at it if you can become an
effective leader even though you have
the right qualities what we need is the
second theme that I want to bring up and
that's mentorship and I promised I would
work merlin into this presentation at
some point so this is a classic mentor
leader relationship the one on thinking
of and probably in your own heads is not
the howard pyle merlin and arthur there
but the disney and th white sword in the
stone by Merlin you know Arthur has the
potential to be a great leader a great
king but he won't realize that unless
Merlin gives him this whole series of
life lessons and so this gets into the
idea of how do you develop and foster
the qualities that will make someone a
leader in future and when I think of the
qualities of a mentor they're not quite
the same i'm looking at qualities like
patients the ability to convey ideas
clearly impatiently understanding of the
individual psychological insight into
what makes people work the way they do
and motivate the others the ability to
encourage and at the same time to be
critical of thinking and not just let it
go awry above all the entire desire to
help someone else realize their
potential now these qualities may or may
not combined with the qualities that
make a good leader so one of the points
here is that in any organization there's
a role here for people who can help
others become leaders and not
necessarily take the lead themselves
overall and just as it's possible to be
effective as
leader and be not a good one it's
impossible to do that as a mentor I'm
not sure Svengali is a idea from the
past and John Barrymore is the actor
from the past I couldn't resist this
slide but Sven golly is a mentor who
develops a star but then wants to
control and the positive mentor is
someone who will develop and then give
up let go let the person develop on
their own now what's the one thing every
leader needs followers no matter how
what you think you're leading if
nobody's following you you're not a
leader and the process of being a
follower can also make you a position
you to become a better leader in future
so following someone that you admire
whose ideas you're working interested in
working on yourselves give you an
opportunity for close-up observation for
a close working relationship with
someone who can help you the opportunity
to be mentored by someone who has shown
that they're interested in that and
successful as well and then lead you to
eventually becoming a leader in your own
right so this is part of that patients
and and timing of developing a career in
the course of it becoming both a
follower and eventually a leader and
many of the leaders of the past had been
followers I just for lack of time put up
a couple of names here you know Plato is
a great philosopher and known to be a
follower of Socrates Isaac Newton I
don't associate with a particular bent
or or leader but he's well known for the
quote if I have seen further it's
because I stand on the shoulder of
giants paying tribute to the people who
led to him to being able to do what he
was able to now I've gotten almost to
the end of my time and I haven't talked
at all about mastery and mysteries so
let me just tell you a few words on that
here we have Daniel Boone ready to lead
a group of Hardy pioneers off into the
wilderness of Kentucky and if you're
going to follow this guy into a place
that you don't know that might be scary
and difficult you want to know that he
knows what he's talking about so a a
true leader also is a master of
something of a body of information the
body of ideas
knowledge and skills that can inspire
others and help others to to have
confidence in their abilities as well
the mystery is inherent I think as we
are leading into new and different and
unknown territories there's bound to be
things that we can't prediction
anticipate in advance and that I think
is one of them are exciting challenges
of both being a leader on following
leader not knowing exactly where you're
going so ideally all this can come
together in one package you find someone
with the the vision to inspire to say I
know a better way of doing things I know
that we can be in a better place trust
me because I've got the skills I got the
knowledge to to convince you that I can
do this successfully and help to make
this work but at the same time I don't
know all the answers we're going to
explore this together that will be a
great opportunity and exciting but it
will also create some some risks as well
and you need to be prepared to take
those along the way I'll do my best to
impart what I do know to to help you to
learn from this process and from me so
that in the end I can step aside when
the time comes and you'll have the
opportunity to explore new paths and new
developments I thank you very time I
hope some of these ideas will be picked
up and explored in other ways in the
course of the day and I hope you have a
very successful next several hours thank
you so Geralyn bailed off is going to
present to us on leadership development
in action she's currently leading
organization development for the
University of Minnesota libraries in the
twin cities and in this role she
provides consultation leadership and
oversight for initiatives that increase
the library's capacity to realize its
strategic priorities and work more
effectively she's given over 75
workshops and presentations and she's
also published a book with a la so
please welcome Geralyn
you
hi everyone thank you for having me um
thanks to Damon who and his colleagues
who brought me here it's so nice to be
back on the East Coast I grew up in
Trenton Elliot did you hear that and we
both we both say border true and we both
leawood I noticed that so just landing
here getting into New York is just such
a relaxing Minnesota is still a foreign
country to me I don't know if you said
the star but I've been there like almost
16 years so it shouldn't be it's kind of
pathetic okay so um some of you know
Wendy lu j she is our our dean at
Minnesota yeah some things and knots she
came here and spoke last year so many of
you may have heard her she she and I had
a chance last week or a couple weeks ago
to talk sit down and talk about our
leadership development programs and she
said this and I so I quickly jotted it
down because I thought it was quite
notable we've done something
game-changing to focus on leadership and
that's that's why I'm here I am your
case study in the wait a minute how does
this look in action that's what we're
trying to do I'm going to share with you
about the deep not a lot of the details
but at least you'll get a nice overview
of what we're doing and I hope it's
going to give you an opportunity to
think about your own interests in
leadership development and even more
importantly your library's interest in
leadership development and i hope you
walk away with a couple things first
thing is that you'll have some ideas of
programs that you could actually
launched in your library and I'm hoping
that you'll have some drive or
motivation to actually do it so we'll
see how I do you can let me know so
first thing I wanna do is introduce you
to a colleague of mine his name's Eric
and he's one of them the many people who
keep our ILS functioning and he's a guy
I never even met him before he came into
this program that i'm going to be
talking about so so the video that i'm
going to show you is just after he
finished what is a core leadership
program in our repertoire of development
programs and it involves doing
assessments
and it involves having one-on-one
coaching and creating an individual
development plan so I'll talk about that
later but I just wanted to give you a
little background he just came out of
the program at the point of the video
where I'm going to start it um and like
I said before before we start I didn't
even know him I'm on millions of
committees millions of projects so I'm
ready to work with a lot of people in
our libraries and I've also worked in
the same building with him for like a
decade I never saw him he's the kind of
head down kind of guy he does his job
he's good at it but he just doesn't get
up and out very much which is not a
typical for four people in his position
and let me let me see if I can t this up
lava okay hopefully the volume will work
let's see so this is patty ignore her
Eric's on Nick's little background this
video I did as a kind of promotional
piece to recruit people into this
program so we've done it three times
this is f to the first year and i will
give you the URL to this if you feel
like watching the whole thing i'm only
gonna show you a couple segments of it
alright let's see it was make it big
maybe i just had not been looking in the
right directions maybe i didn't see the
potential that i had maybe other people
weren't seeing the potential that i had
but it looked like i was stuck in the
same track probably from now till when
my career with libraries might be over
but here I am at age 55 and I've been
giving it up given an opportunity to
reinvent myself and this program was
sort of the spark that got the whole
thing going
ok so I hope you heard that he said this
program was sort of the spark that got
the whole thing going it's very uncommon
if it's very common for people in our
programs especially this core program
who feels stuck many of them have been
working in the same job for a long time
they've been in the same library for a
long time we have very little we have a
turnover very little turnover in her
library we have really long-term
employees and to the extent that I have
a friend who works in she was doing her
master's in HR and she did a study about
longevity across campus and she pulled
me aside and said I was shocked the
libraries are like our outliers you're
you're crazy off-the-charts in terms of
longevity so 25 30 year 40 year people
work in the libraries and this is one of
them he made he made his career to this
job 55 years old felt stuck thought he
had potential that was untapped this is
a pretty common profile of people who
get who were drawn into the program this
specifically this program I want to
introduce you to one other person by way
of introduction to some of the things
we're doing this is ryan Mackey he's
more at the beginning of his career he's
an archivist and he runs a special
collection he's got a few people who do
report to him and so this is right after
he went through the first year of this
program it's a nine month program all
right let me see if I can t this up Wow
alright hold on for a second
it's gonna make it diseased look away
look away Lucia Lucia has increasingly
been I think that I've sent I'm doing
and what the assembly so it's actually I
didn't have a lot of these passion
fruits that would make good and
effective leaders and being intentional
on the Delta that African the started at
SMA a cute about Dorothy okay so this is
another another person who is a really
good candidate for programs heat yeah
he's dabbling as a leader he's starting
to kind of think about himself that way
but he doesn't have much confidence he's
not quite sure where he wants to move in
his career so another really good
candidate for at least our big basic
program let me get back to our slides
so as I said a lot of people come into
the programs especially the core
leadership programs uncertain about
themselves as leader they haven't yet
really fully created a leadership
identity so they don't necessarily see
themselves as a leader but they're
curious they think there might be
potential and they just don't know what
to do with it they just need a little
help and for whatever reason their
supervisor isn't able to do that kind of
coaching and mentoring or they don't
have a mentor in the profession they're
kind of on their own kind of floundering
a bit I want to talk about this
leadership identity a little bit more
because i think it is so crucial and
it's something that that we need to
intentionally cultivate in our libraries
and i'll talk a little bit about why but
let me just say that this is important
and a lot of leadership identity comes
out of having first thing you have to do
is you have to have what's called a
growth mindset okay this is a really
good book has anybody been able to read
it yeah I've got a couple people who've
raised their hand this is one of those
things I was in the airport when I was
coming over here and I looked in the
bookstore it it's you know one of the
how many hundreds of books that made it
through to the bookstore at the airport
so it's been read a lot um it's the work
the work the person who wrote this is a
psychologist at Stanford and in this
book she goes into many many many of the
ways in which our beliefs about our own
ability to grow and develop shape every
aspect of our lives and she found that
there are some people who believe their
personal traits are fixed and there are
some people that believe they can be
developed and this is really fundamental
the fixed mindset is the one I want to
focus on this is the mindset that gets
us into trouble so the fixed mindset is
when you believe your intelligence or
your personality never really change how
your board is how you'll die and you've
got 120 IQ when you're 12 you're going
to have 120 IQ when you're 90 it doesn't
matter what
you do so if you have a fixed mindset
you are going your morge much more
likely to invest everything you've got
into proving that you're smart it's
interesting how this would correlate
correlates with a competency trap I like
to look into that you may be too afraid
to ask questions and a venue like this
or if you do ask questions you tend to
ask them in a way that just shows how
smart you are or how capable you are
it's a way of getting approval and a
sort of stamp of affirmation the fixed
mindset will prevent you from trying
anything new because you don't want to
fail you're afraid of failure you can't
stand the idea of not being the best at
something and I am sad to say but my
daughter has his mind set she is a fixed
mindset person and she was like that now
my son is not my son is really a growth
mindset person but my daughter for
whatever reason is a fixed mindset
person so this is a picture of her on
her first day of kindergarten so what do
you do in kindergarten what do you learn
you learn how to read do you know how
difficult this is for a fixed mindset
person because for the first six months
of kindergarten she had no idea what she
was doing she was failing she was
blundering she was basically revealing
to herself and others that she wasn't
that smart she thought she was smart but
maybe she's not so smart it's hard to
learn to read I am still to this day
what is it March i'm still at this day
the only person she will read to when
she's practicing for some reason she'll
allow me to see her fail or are see her
incompetent but she doesn't want anybody
else to see her that way I really really
feel for her this is a brilliant
problematic mindset to have to start
your life like this it's my job as her
mother adjusts wallack my fur luster ahh
see I'm so emotional about it it really
does it deeply concerns me my job as her
mother mr. culture into a growth mindset
I don't have to do this with my son he
already has it and here's the thing
that's so sad about the fixed mindset is
that these are folks who plateau early
they never meet their full potential
because they don't want to be not
competent right they don't want to look
not so smart and that's what kills me
these are the people who get stuck in a
job for life they get really really good
at something and they don't want it they
don't never want to step out and be
incompetent even if it's just for six
months or just for a year or it just
means they have to go to some
development programs a little bit and
get some mentoring and coaching they're
not going to step out it's really too
frightening so think about this in terms
of your life which one of these mindsets
growth mindset or fixed mindset really
describes you now of course I haven't
really talked about the growth mindset
you can read the book and learn about it
but I'm assuming that you're picking up
on what a growth mindset is this is when
you actually feel like you can grow and
change and develop and that failure is a
learning experience it's not a
reflection on your competency or your
intelligence it's a whole other paradigm
and I actually am thankful for the whole
gaming industry because I think that is
partly why my slot is can have a growth
mindset because games are made for
people with growth mindsets you fail you
screw up you get killed you come back
you keep coming back you get more lives
and I love that and then you get to this
level and then to get to that level and
I wish my daughter would play video
games so think about your library now
you've thought about yourself now think
about your library does your culture
does your library culture have a fixed
mindset or does your library culture
have a growth
mine said haha can you you want to say
something you have nothing to say okay
so if you have a if your organization I
mean I don't even know if this is really
like kosher if you can really see it
this way but I'm going to I'm going to
say it if your organization has a fixed
mindset once people are hired you know
once you've got a good you hire for
competency you hire for experience you
hire somebody who's done the job before
and once they get in that job you just
that's it they're done they've they've
aspired to what their achievement being
in a growth mindset organization this is
where hard work this is where effort
gets rewarded effort is not a reflection
that you're dumb or you know not
something isn't coming easily to you
which means something about you and a
growth mindset organization hard work
and in failure are good things because
it means we're learning we're constantly
learning coaching is something that's
valuable learning development is
something that's valuable you are full
of potential and a growth mindset
organization and a fixed mindset
organization you've already reached your
potential you're working in your
potential thank you very much so you can
see our growth mindset in our vision
mission and overall goal for our
leadership programs the vision is to
build a vibe and I'm so sorry if you're
a designer and you're just like hating
this slide I really really am sorry I
don't know what I was thinking red and
blue really or bad so if you are
designer and you'd like to volunteer
some time to design my slice I would be
appreciated okay my apologies ok so our
vision build a vibrant leadership
culture in the university libraries
build I mean that's another word for
growth mindset organization right their
mission is to develop current and
emerging leaders growth mindset we can
emerge as leaders at all levels
leadership writ large and we
already had people talk about leadership
is not about if your manager or if
you're a director if you're an associate
university librarian leadership at all
levels is our is our definition of
leadership so what is our goal in our
programs it's to strengthen our ability
to be effective and successful by
preparing and supporting current and
emerging leaders at all levels and let
me I need I feel like I just need to
take a few moments even though probably
don't but I'm going to do it anyway to
just underscore why this is so important
to us why we're committed to this there
are three reasons the first is that
there is no time to waste I feel like
you know that like pac-man thing it's
like alba gobble gobble gobble gobble
gobble it's like coming after us funding
funding funding junk junk junk junk
every year and every year we're running
ahead of it creating new initiatives new
services new value for a community and
this is just a little like overview of
the many what i would call initiatives
that we are launching or have launched
and are keeping afloat in the libraries
now a friend a colleague and I a collie
friend and I sat down and we
brainstormed all the program areas that
come out of each one of these
initiatives there are 20 each one of
these program areas I'll just read out
some for the people in the back just to
give you a sample so if you look under
research data the first circle we have
programs like management and curation
data literacy data visualization
geospatial data under interdisciplinary
research we have digital humanities we
have collaboration in those efforts we
have metrics and impact which is another
program there are 20 programs that we
are running in the libraries we can't
have Wendy and our associate University
librarians running all those they can't
lead all of these programs it's just not
possible every one of these programs has
to have at least one leader sometimes
two leaders to run these programs the
the the work is too specialized
it's too complex for any one person at
the top to handle it all it's like
they're out there they're kind of like
flying the plane as they build it so we
have all of this need for layers and
then God who doesn't have a million
projects and committees anymore it's
like all the work of the library now
seems to be done in projects all I feel
like I do is I do project management
training for people I mean God and the
committee's you know how it is like we
are so incredibly collaborative and we
need the leaders we need leaders for
every single one of these and then a
third reason why we're very very
committed to this I don't know has
anybody read the leadership pipeline
this is such a good book if anyone here
is interested in climbing sort of the
the traditional ladder you know
management and so forth in libraries I
really think you should read this is
written for the corporate community but
it's fabulous and what I did here is I
showed what's called a pipeline and I
plugged in the words that we use in the
libraries for this pipeline let me tell
you a little bit about it because it
really also feeds very well into the
competency trap notion that Elliot
talked about so so I do have a pointer
right ok so down here we all start as
individual contributors if you're an
injured individual contributor you have
a certain skill set in your functional
area you have certain values and beliefs
about your work and typically if you're
an individual collaborator your values
and beliefs are about your work it's
your the focus you're the focus here the
other the third thing is you have a
certain way of allocating your time
right you spend most of your time doing
your functional work your job is to
develop your competency and your
expertise in your functional area and
then what happens when you get promoted
so in our I don't know about your
libraries but in our libraries you've
been sitting around in the same job for
10 20 years how the heck else are you
going to get any kind of salary increase
if we don't promote you
how do we how do we recognize you pat
you on the back for your extreme
expertise in your functional area we
promote you congratulations now you're a
supervisor and your expected whoopsie
you're expected to make this passage
from individual contributor to
supervisor and no mostly you're expected
do it on your own you're going to pick
it up as you go you're smart but what
happens you're in the competency track
this is where you're good you're down
haired individual contributor your
expertise in your functional area is
where you shine and now you're doing
work you don't even know why what it
entails what is before mismanagement
have you even heard of it before what's
developmental coaching I don't know what
am I supposed to be doing with my time
my job description hardly says anything
about supervisor huh look at this most
of my job description still about my
functional work so what do i do i do my
functional work I don't make the passage
from individual contributor up to
supervisor and then what happens I screw
that passage of run and then I've been
there long enough and I'm good enough
and I'm smart enough then what out then
I get promoted up to director now my job
is to actual is to coach supervise
mentor my supervisors but if I never
made the passage correctly to
supervision how do I help coach and
mentor those people to do their good job
because I don't even really get their
job so what happens here is the pipeline
starts get all clogged up it gets
clogged up with people who haven't
haven't transferred having made the
passage to the next level each passage
and necessitates three things new skills
new values and beliefs and new time
allocation if those three things don't
adjust at each passage you've clogged up
the pipeline what happens when you don't
know how to do your new job you don't
want to look stupid you want to do what
makes you feel good and what you're good
at which is your functional work so you
spend your time doing that and you just
blow off the management stuff you don't
even know what that entails anyway
really and nobody is on your tail about
it because they don't care either they
about your functional work right so what
happens what happens in an organization
we have something called under
management I did not coin this term
under management my head of HR did but
we have highly under managed libraries
so we're being managed by people who had
ten percent of their time if there's a
fire if there's a problem i'll be your
manager if everything's going okay y'all
be fine so what happens when you're
managed by somebody or supervise but
somebody is just like you come to me
when there's a problem I'll see you next
month you're under managed and this is a
fabulous little graph that I pulled out
of a gallup study this little study is
called the state it's not little Amongus
is like 25 million data points okay but
it's called the state of the American
workplace and so what it does is it
shows let's see if I can explain this
the the yellow 57% 50 so if you are
under managed if you're one of those
individuals underneath the person who's
under managing you it is likely that a
fifty-seven percent of you are not
engaged you're just not engaged in your
work okay all right that's that's not
not so nice but the black one is forty
percent of our you are actively
disengaged the actively disengaged
people are the toxic people in the
organization these are the people that
just spread negativity that run trot
proper after every meeting they don't
speak up they are disengaged in their
pissed and they spread it around so this
is this is like this is the scary thing
I mean it's sad to be not engaged in
your work but to be actively disengaged
is worse and then this little bit
smoother you can hardly see is two
percent guess guess who the two
percenters are ya the ones that were
engaged so congratulations if you made
it to the two percent it probably means
you are very dedicated and you're very
dedicated committed and dedicated to
your work and to your students to your
faculty to whomever you are sir
serving I have a feeling in libraries we
would our slice would be a little bit
bigger because we are so outward focused
so those are three really good reasons
why we're very very interested in
leadership development the first thing
is that we are spawning a ton of
initiatives with programs connected to
them that need leadership we are doing
more and more of our work in projects
and committees and the third is that we
really care about the pipeline we don't
want to plug up the pipeline an
engagement is very important to us we do
a university-wide engagement survey we
have data and what is day to do what
does measurement do it spurs you to
action so we are very interested in
engagement and the impact that managers
have aan engagement alright so I've said
a lot here by we have sort of
introduction to the programs it's
quarter after okay so I got to get a
kick goin here all right so we have this
disel honeycomb thing is a big picture
of all the different programs that we
are running in our library you're like
oh my god that's a lot i would love you
i'm going to go through these fairly
quickly hope i can what I'd like you to
listen for is what's possible for you so
not everything is going to work for your
library but some pieces might or some
ways to adapt these programs might work
for you so that's what I'd like you to
be thinking about as we go through this
and if I do have an overview of all
these programs by the way and i will
give you the URL at the end of the
session all right so first oh and then
i'm going to talk about how much it
costs okay so the first program i want
it i want to introduce by way of this
introduction I mean this quote I've
never met an effective leader who wasn't
aware of his talents and working to
sharpen them and our first program our
core program does both it helps you
become very self-aware and it helps you
sharpen your skills and your strengths
okay it's the cornerstone of our all of
our management our leadership programs
we'd blah we've done this through three
times oh look there's a nice little
bathroom right there that's handy we've
done this three times now so we're in
our third year of this particular
program we put 12 people through it
every year you have to apply you are
selected it's a represents a mix of
people from across the organization's we
have a labor we have every different
level of the organization this is not
for the usual suspects and you'll see a
quote about that in a little bit we have
people from every single part of our
libraries involved in this program from
technical services to IT two-minute XR
interlibrary loan everything then this
is not exactly this isn't actually one
cohort this picture this is a mix of the
three cohorts and they came together for
a focus group so I just have to picture
ok so the program is consists of these
four things down here the first thing
our assessment self is one of them is a
self-assessment I can talk about what
that is if anybody is interested and
it's also in our overview but basically
it helps you understand yourself in
three different areas in your
relationships in how you in your
thinking patterns your mindset and your
feelings and emotions so that eq piece
the second major assessment is a multi
Raider assessment has anybody here done
a 360 maybe some people yeah this is a
tremendous experience this is when your
supervisor and your supervisors
supervisor I'll rate you on a huge
battery of questions and you have your
peers do the same thing you choose your
peers and then if you have direct
reports they also do the same for you so
you had it's called 360 because you get
feedback from everyone and it's really
unfettered feedback it's anonymous so it
can be it's a tremendous insightful a
tremendously insightful tool and then
once you do those assessments there's a
coaching component so I iyer are a
contract with outside coaches reveal
people like who actually got degrees in
this area hill then work with you
one-on-one to figure out now you got all
this data what does that mean what does
it tell you and then
they start to help you develop or create
your individual development plan so
that's sort of so what I learned all
this all these things about myself and
now what am I going to do how am I going
to focus and the coach walks you through
that kind of hand holds you through that
and then once you're done with the
coaching part well in the middle of that
then we move you into a peer coaching
component so you're in a triad with two
other colleagues who are also going
through the same process and you meet
and you work together on your individual
development plan on developing it and
then on implementation so that's the
basic program the individual development
program when I when we I pitch this I
pitch this as a self-awareness and
confidence building program because that
really is what it is so remember i
talked about cultivating a leadership
identity this is about really like when
it gets down to it this is cultivating
your leadership identity where are you
strong where do you need to shore up
your skills where do you need to develop
and what do you want it how do you want
to develop and it's not just necessarily
as you as a leader in this sort of
traditional way it's also where do you
want to take your career what's your
vision for yourself it's a very very
personal process and it's done mostly
one-on-one between you and your coach
and you and your peer coaches I have
tons of quotes and probably because I
chose red and blue you can't read them I
asked participants at all I think I uh I
survey people to death so here's one of
the the comments that I thought was a
very nice framing for the whole program
for this particular program she said I
think we create the world we live in
every day for ourselves this program
provided the steps and the structure to
define what we want and how to achieve
it in turn this institution created a
group of individuals who are positive
thinking forward directed and confident
and they are bringing that approach to
work with them every day in that lovely
that is really a nice lovely framing
compa a quote I have lots of other ones
this is from a librarian who is in her
second career she's probably in her 50s
can you read this in the back okay I'll
let you read it
okay so this was just instrumental I
mean she was really at a crossroad she
was she talked to me about it she was
thinking this was not the right decision
for her she felt like she couldn't bring
her full personality her full self to
the job and this program helped her
figure out ways to deal with that
address it and I'd really step out step
into her own leadership I also asked the
supervisors of the people in the program
what they think and I have to say that
over overall confidence comes out at the
top again self identity is leaders I
mean people it's sometimes they just
need a little cultivating and a little
support to step fully into that identity
as a leader so this is a this is one of
one quote from one of the supervisors
here's another these are real problems
that people were having that the
supervisors neces couldn't necessarily
fix they couldn't address it they didn't
know how to do that so some really nice
benefit so I hope that you're thinking
in your head cost-benefit analysis cost
cost benefit analysis as you're looking
at these all right so let me look at the
concerns the biggest concern from the
supervisors is not knowing what calls
what there's no causation here it's not
like you put a person through this
program and you can say ha here's what
happened because there's too many other
things that are going on in the
environment too many other things about
the individual so that's over over
across the board that is the basically
the only concern that supervisors have I
don't know if it's this program or if
it's other things that are making a
difference something is making a
difference this whole thing about
attendees do seem to appreciate the
effort I have to say is really important
I don't know how many people in these
programs have said wow they picked me me
you know I've just been working in
my cue ball this time somebody sees some
potential in me Wow I mean just that
alone is worth its weight in gold so
yeah they have concerns about it because
they don't really know what the program
is actually doing what the impact is
having on impact that every time I ask
them about their concerns they came up
with a yeah I have this concern but and
here are the butts and those are really
really important but these butts our
ettinger have driven a program to run
for three years and we're expanding the
program next year and I'll talk a little
bit about that so what's what's it worth
to people that's really where the rubber
meets the road if your supervisor if
somebody in this program how much would
you pay out of your operations budget
your discretionary budget to put
somebody through a program like this
that's really where I think it we learn
about the value and so here's what we
heard sixty-six percent of the
supervisors were willing to swell one
person wasn't willing to spend anything
so they didn't see any value into the
program one out of 18 people who
responded but sixty-six percent said at
least they'd spend they might spend up
to seven hundred fifty dollars of their
own men we don't get any money up by the
way very little discretionary funding so
there's no like ample you know pool of
money here to pull to pull from thirty
three percent that said they spent
between 750 to two thousand dollars per
/ staff member that's how valuable they
thought it was oops alright so how much
does this cost per person okay actually
it hardly cost us anything at all
because I this is so this is the sort of
the secret to all these programs is that
we have a very very good spot small
office on our campus called
organizational effectiveness it's out of
HR central HR and they are consultants
and trainers who are their sole job is
oh my god all right five minutes
but I do need to say this because you
need to leverage the people on your
campus who can do these programs for
free ok so it's part of their job to
work with clients like us we just happen
to use a lot of them and use them
frequently so if we were going to pay
for this this is what i would pay all
right not a lot per person Emily it's
nice to see you but I'm going to skip
you for now this is another testimonial
but how important this was this is
another person who just didn't have the
confidence until she went through the
program now she's a supervisor but she
wasn't prior to this Eric same thing he
was not a super not that like all our
people go through the program and that
being supervisors but they certainly get
a chance to really look at that deeply
and see if that's where they want to go
some people choose not to and some
people choose to supervisor fundamentals
is another program that we offer so I
showed you that pipeline right and where
people get stuck if you get stuck at
that first passage you're toast so we
don't want people getting stuck at that
first passage so this is a semester-long
half-day immersion in just into coral
supervisory skills this is where you
learn what developmental coaching is
this is what you learn what performance
management is this is what you learn how
you learn about discipline instead of
taking five or ten years like it took
for me on the job to learn this stuff by
osmosis we make sure you have all the
basics in this program so you can make
the passage nothing because we rely on
that again that HR function on campus we
have another program called the
directors cohort now this is an
opportunity for our director level
people to get together over lunch to
talk about issues that are concerned to
them I don't set an agenda nobody sets
an outside agenda every six weeks we
meet and it's completely confidential
this is where you learn from your
colleagues this is where you get advice
this is where you learn best practices
and I'm not going to read these to you
but I want to say that the second bullet
I was a brand new director and he has
just waxed on about without the right
word about how important this program
has been for him to learn his job
quickly and effectively it's a rare
opportunity to talk with directors
outside of your own
realm there's a little or no opportunity
to do it elsewhere
you
ok moving on cost us about 80 bucks and
I say it's about 80 bucks because I buy
lunch this form and by box lunches for
him every six weeks big deal right per
person so all right I have another
program called off for managers it's a
peer coaching program again doesn't cost
us anything I just set up the group I
teach them how to do peer coaching give
them some parameters and then they're on
their own so I actually put them in we
put them into trait triode so that they
are not working with anybody in their
traditional realm they're getting out
and about meeting new people getting new
insights and mixing it up again very
highly confidential conversations that
happen in the peer coaching groups this
is where you can have a sounding board
this is where you get advice
this is where you get neutral feedback
and you learn history around things that
you have no idea why is they doing that
huh I don't get it this is where you
come
total cost per person 0 then the closets
anything that for peer coaching program
you can do this very quickly grand total
for all the programs that we have so far
if we pay to outsource remember the
assessments in the coaching in that
first program that's where all the money
is now I've only paid for that one out
of three years because the other two
years I've gotten the services for free
from this central group that one year I
didn't is because they were realigning
their priorities and they didn't want to
commit to the program so i had to pay
for it other people to do it all right
plus my time I keep saying that and I
don't is it 1130 I don't really have a
lot of any way you can ask me about this
later what does it mean but what is my
timing we have four other programs that
we are just beginning to launch the one
here with the arrow is called leading at
the director in program level it is a
traditional classroom experience as a
three-day immersion and we're doing that
next month and then the piece after that
this honeycomb in the upper right hand
corner which is the directors individual
development program is by request to the
directors they've been seeing like all
their people go through the individual
development program they want to do it
so now they're going to get to do the
360's they're going to get to do the
self assessments they're going to get
the coaching and there you know the
whole shebang we have a mentoring
program that's going to more official
program with lots of structure and
expectations that's going to be
launching end of spring and then we have
a manager's program over here this left
lower honeycomb that is yes okay that is
I'm just beginning to develop this is
going to be a one sprinkled out
throughout the year so every month a two
hour to two and a half hour sort of
classroom and discussion training so
think about where you are in terms of
your investment I'm going to skip over
this real quick but i just wanted to
show you in contrast what the private
sector spends per person annually just
to give you some sort of benchmark and
then i want to show you what we spend
this is
development plus other things plus my
time so really remarkably little for
amazing outcome and benefit so 300 vs
left at 1200 drop in the bucket I also
want to make sure that we are all well
aware how much were worth two million
dollars now this is very conservative so
what I did was I made the math I think I
said if we pay somebody $50,000 which is
like a drop in the bucket out here I
know but if you pay somebody $50,000 and
they work for you for 30 years and then
you give them fringe you've got a
two-million-dollar employee in front of
you you are all worth much more than 2
million dollars in this room I bet
that's a lot of money how much are we
spending a month on your develop a year
on your development so i did i did a
little quick math if we spend three
hundred dollars a year on your
development for 30 years we've only
spent nine thousand dollars over your
lifetime of employment nine thousand
dollars to develop you and what you cost
us two million dollars okay Wow is that
off for what so I think there's a lot of
room here a ton of room here to improve
our development and our investment in
development I'd like you to think about
your development plan if you have one we
should all have one what job related
skills what you need a year from now are
you thinking about that are you thinking
about what you might need for three
years from now are you thinking about
what you need to learn now to have the
biggest impact on your success are you
thinking about that now if not start
writing that down start thinking about
that talk with a collie even if you
don't have a program to help you develop
it you can do it with a friend or
colleague or in part of you as part of
your unit I just want to underscore
again leadership ISM is a an identity
it's not a position it doesn't matter if
you're in a formal position of
leadership or or not we need you at all
levels to be a leader this is important
to people very very important to people
do you see this this is what somebody
said when we started advertising the
first court the core program Wow haha
this is not just another program that
identifies the usual suspects wow this
could be for me
eric has some lovely things to say
please watch this video if you could
design the perfect leadership
development program at lot your library
what would it look like what would you
pull from what we've done what would you
adopt why don't you do it here's your
leadership assignment go do it your
total challenge here after today is the
cult begin doing what you can to
cultivate a culture of leadership in
your libraries help to cultivate a
growth mindset in your libraries use
adapt or invent your own leadership
program leadership programs use ours go
ahead and host one yourself just take on
one and just say you're going to do it
your leadership your leadership
development opportunity is right here I
also got this it was like somebody hit
me on the head why don't we offer this
program to everybody I work four days a
week I have a fifth day what the heck am
i doing on my fifth day I could be
offering you the individual development
program so it doesn't matter if you're
here in New York or if you're in
Minnesota we can do this online we can
get this accomplished you can do your
coaching on google hangouts if you want
to go through a program like I explained
would you please go ahead and go to this
URL Z umn.edu / IDP interest and let me
know you're interested and if you're
interested I will do it all right I
promised you some URLs the video that I
showed you overview of all the programs
in my contact information is right here
so thank you for your time
you